let's German Tom Cruise
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you yes yes
welcome welcome to our Foolish show be
back here yeah yeah you know I gotta say
first of all I get to talk to a lot of
people over the what are 25 years I've
been doing this I think I can safely say
you might be the most famous the most
iconic faces in the world and I was
thinking about it today because we hung
out a little bit today because you
always want your counting time and Tom's
always let me own time and we were
hanging out at the convention center in
like a private area just talking before
presentation and it occurred to me you
might be one of the only people I know
who's so famous you could probably walk
the convention floor and people would
think there's no way that's Tom Cruise
he would not be out here you could go
with no makeup and just walk around and
if someone said you're not you're like
are you kidding come on
like I would walk around here yeah
exactly would you ever consider doing
something like that that would be fun
actually
yeah that'd be that happens I sometimes
I walk around in some agree you look
just like Tom Cruise and what do you do
in that situation I say you know I get
that I get that yeah and I get which
Belgian woman are you
you know it's fine so I introduced you
on ha and Hall H and no thank you visit
thrill and it was fun to watch everyone
lose their minds and the minute you come
out people in the audience are all
screaming out all your iconic lines now
one an actor is lucky to have one
they're screaming at people are yelling
out you complete me I feel the need for
speed you know you had me at hello
everyone's got their own which is the
one you get the most do you think I
don't know which one I get the most to
be asked I mean what's that show me the
money
yeah I'll be the money show me the money
please let's go sleep please tell please
tell me Tom that you yelled at at your
atm okay yes I would do anything
and then and then you add in 20